Thank You Mara it is always a pleasure
to welcome the associates to the museum
this is your Museum of American history
and it's it's great to be the venue for
lectures and for conferences and
symposiums sponsored by the by the
associates how many of you have visited
fallingwater
Wow Franklin you have a very
well-informed audience here ah say if
you if you've already visited I think
you will go back again with a nutria
nude appreciation once you hear this
lecture by Franklin Tucker if you have
not visited Fallingwater I know you will
be inspired to visit once you have heard
this program it's a great pleasure to be
part of this program and to introduce
Franklin Coker who is a longtime friend
of mine a respected colleague he's made
enormous contributions to the field of
architectural history his work on
falling water reminds us that there's
more than more of a story here than just
a work of architecture there are some
intriguing personal stories associated
with this with this magnificent building
magnificent sight that he has drawn out
in his in his research and in his
writing Franklin Coker is president
emeritus of the Society of architectural
historians and he is a professor of art
and architecture at the University of
Pittsburgh where he teaches urban
history and the history of medieval and
American architecture an art historian
and a medieval archaeologist dr. toker
has published three books and several
dozen scholarly articles on topics
including Roman archaeology gothic
architectural drawings Renaissance
architectural theory the work of HH
Richardson postmodern architecture and
American urban history his first book
the Church of notre-dame at Mont and
Montreal which was published in 1971 won
the Hitchcock Award as the most
distinguished new book on the history of
architecture in 1980 the College Art
Association awarded his art bulletin
article on the Florence Cathedral the
Porter prize for the best essay on any
branch of art in 1986 he published
Pittsburgh and urban portrait a highly
regarded text on the architecture
history and development of Pittsburgh
and the western Pennsylvania region and
last year his book falling water rising
was published on Frank Lloyd Wright's
masterpiece in western Pennsylvania
Franklin toker has held appointments as
a member of the Institute for Advanced
Study at Princeton he has been a
Guggenheim Fellow a fellow of the villa
I Tatti in Florence and a senior fellow
for the National Endowment for the
Humanities he has degrees from in fine
arts from McGill University Oberlin
College and Harvard University please
join me in welcoming the to the
Smithsonian associates this immensely
talented
engaging and respected teacher scholar
and writer
dr. Franklin Coker
[Applause]
laughter glass I thank you for that
introduction and for the honor you and
the Smithsonian associates do me tonight
in having me speaker ladies and
gentlemen frank lloyd wright's
Fallingwater has been characterized as
the best building in the United States
the best work of architecture anywhere
in the last hundred years the best house
anywhere anytime and the best work of
American art you're entitled to disagree
with those assessments of course but
here is one you cannot fight
unquestionably the most famous private
residence ever built
but why give a talk about architecture
at the National Museum of American
history why broadcast it on c-span which
is oriented to politics what's
historical about a private house not yet
three score and seven years old and I'll
answer fallingwater is not just a house
it is an American icon with links to
Franklin D Roosevelt Albert Einstein and
Rand William Randolph Hearst and Henry
are loose among others and I'll argue
tonight that you can find few
testimonies that better articulate what
the United States went through in the
1930s that wrenching decade in which our
country was buffeted by warfare and want
fallingwater
is also an important witness to a global
struggle about architectural politics in
the years between the two world wars
primarily involving America and Germany
and if this struggle strikes you as
trivial maybe akin to the struggle of
Britney Spears and Christina Aguilera
think about this
the scaffolding came off falling water
in October 1937 the exact month in which
the Nazis shut down the Bauhaus the
world's most influential school of
modern architecture sending its faculty
fleeing mainly to the United States
fallingwater
is
peculiar American icon an instant icon
as I subtitle tonight's talk a house
that took its place alongside Mount
Vernon and Monticello at warp speed
history was not made at falling water
rather history was the mortar of which
falling water was built the house
encapsulate s' the architectural history
of our nation in its every walling and
flooring from the timber-framed houses
and Stone Barns of the Northeast to the
ancient shrines of the Native Americans
in the southwest so let's proceed to
that curious ritual called author
talking about his new book keeping in
mind Margaret Atwood's observation that
wanting to meet an author because you
like his book is a little like wanting
to meet a duck because you like pate the
story of Fallingwater
begins with Kaufman's department store
in Pittsburgh shown here as it was in
1905 its profits made millionaires out
of three generations of Kaufman's the
first generation Kauffman brothers came
from Germany during the Civil War within
four decades they had blanketed
Pittsburgh with their mansions clubs
synagogues and charitable institutions
the members of the 2nd and 3rd Kauffman
generations who built falling water were
Edgar all was called EJ on the left his
wife Lillian on the right and their son
Edgar jr. in the middle EJ and Lillian
were first cousins and indeed Lillian's
parents were also first cousins makes
you think of a great German Jewish
dynasty like the Rothschilds and no
question these were the Rothschilds of
Pittsburgh racing their french-bread
horses against the witness and
collecting Renaissance Madonna's not at
the beginning people concerned with
modernism at all
but they were people determined to
stretch the envelope of Pittsburgh
Society
here's Lillian in a pretty unusual pose
for a society matron then or now the
breasts belong to a model in Vienna
by the way Lillian was brilliant as a
merchant so we perhaps call this an
early instance of anatomical outsourcing
Stanley Marcus of Neiman Marcus in
Dallas told me straight out that EJ
Kauffman was the smartest retailer in
America EJ became the merchant Prince of
Pittsburgh when he and his spouse cousin
Lillian took over their family store in
1910 but Kaufman's position was as his
lawyer put it so delicately to me
anomalous within Pittsburg society
Pittsburghers like Andrew Carnegie Henry
Clay Frick HJ Heinz George Westinghouse
and the melons all of the men Kaufman
knew and dealt with were not only much
richer they were the industrialist who's
miles long factories encircled the city
Kaufmann was just a merchant and the
Pittsburgh establishment never let him
forget it Kaufman reigned over a tiny
Empire nonetheless not in Pittsburgh but
45 miles to the southeast deep in the
Pennsylvania woods where he discovered a
waterfall on a stream called Bear Run EJ
leased and then bought this land as a
summer resort for his employees some of
whom you see enjoying it here in 1933
Kaufmann chased out the employees and
applied to Washington to have his land
temporarily classified as a CCC work
camp it was legal to have the CCC boys
reforest private property but it
demanded the personal override of the
President of the United States
and FDR shown here with some of the CCC
participants in the background must of
guffawed plenty as he rejected the
efforts of a Pittsburgh millionaire to
get the taxpayers to give a free
touch-up to his lordly domain back to
the drawing board
EJ had no interest in the CCC itself
what he wanted at Bear Run was not a
work camp but the resulting fine estate
on which he could erect a showplace
weekend house given his spotty track
record as an architectural patron before
falling water that house should have
been pretty conventional here for
example is Kaufman's house in Pittsburgh
the exterior represents the high quality
but strictly academic work that many
rich Americans were putting up in the
1920s and early 30s stock broker Tudor
it's often called inside the house was
fashionably stuffy to the point of
claustrophobia
this was the hopelessly backward setting
in which Kaufman and Frank Lloyd Wright
first discussed building falling water
but Kaufman was simultaneously educating
himself in architecture he carefully
studied the most advanced commercial
architecture in the world which was in
Germany brilliantly progressive
buildings like Erik Mendelssohn's 1926
shockin store in Stuttgart
but we're caught immediately by a
certain irony here the store is no more
than an update of the carson puri scott
store in Chicago by Wright's old teacher
Louis Sullivan turn-of-the-century
America had patented modern architecture
but it hadn't developed it that lead had
gone to Germany and it was in Germany
that Kaufmann discovered modernism he
was American born but he spoke read and
wrote good German
and he carefully refurbished his links
with Germany each year Germany for him
was not the old country remembered in
gastronomy and mumbled song it was a
vibrantly new country where the
university's technology business
administration and german cultur in
general were markedly superior to their
American counterparts here was a
cultural and commercial well from which
Kaufmann would not cease to draw until
Hitler plugged it shut Kaufmann
remodeled the ground floor of his store
in 1930 at which point he stood halfway
to modernism the store was our de Cohen
style modernistic rather than hard-edged
modern it was four years later that
Kaufmann turned to Frank Lloyd Wright
for his weekend home Wright was a
peculiar choice for the merchant who was
legendary for keeping up with the latest
in styles not because Wright was ahead
of the times as a modernist but the
opposite by the early 1930s Wright was
finished washed up as a leading edged
architect he had built just half a dozen
houses since 1922 just one single house
since 1928 I called the chapter and
write in my book
the dead man of modern architecture
plunk plans a comeback because Wright
was 67 years old when Kaufmann picked
him to design falling water he
desperately needed a comeback not
because he was old but because he was
artistically dead the Robie house of
1909 represents what seemed to be a
modernist takeover that was imminent at
the turn of the 20th century but in fact
this was an illusion progressive
designers would not wrest power from the
Conservatives for another half century
strangely American buildings after World
War one were often more conservative
than those before the war
the war made European architects take
refuge in the future while American
architecture took refuge in the past the
new Supreme Court of 1935 presented
itself as a Greek temple of such
unabashed classicism that except for its
electrical wiring it could have carried
the date of 1835 or maybe 435 BC it
staggers the mind the troglodytes like
these overlapped with the building of
falling water but the Conservatives were
not the worst of rights enemies I open
my book with a quote from Oscar Wilde
nothing is so dangerous as being too
modern one is apt to grow old fashioned
quite suddenly right had been blindsided
by the far more radical modernists in
Europe men like Walter Gropius here is
gropius's famous Bauhaus of 1925 Mies
van der Rohe
and the curb is yae an apprentice
confirmed for me that whenever writes
swatted flies he would gleefully
announce the window kill as gut Gropius
got Mies Kotla Corbusier here is the
1929 villa savoir a machine for living
in the Corbusier famously said of this
and other of his fastidiously
mechanistic houses even more radical was
the plan for a country villa that Mies
van der OA drop in 1923 a plan so
abstract and ethereal
that even today 81 years later it gives
no hint of being intended for human
habitation the irony was that the
Europeans had used Wright as their
starting point the great publication on
his work was the two-volume portfolio
that he had published in 1910 not in the
United States but in Germany the
Europeans looked at rights tentatively
cubist early work
is the Laura Gail house of 1909 and then
they reworked it Gerrit Rietveld 1923
Schreuder house in Utrecht for example
blasted the Gail house apart then glued
the bits and pieces together where they
fell Wright's ultimate humiliation came
in 1932 New York's Museum of Modern Art
was planning the most important exhibit
ever held on modern architecture before
or since and Wright was not invited to
be part of it
only backroom politics the MoMA trustees
demanded some token American
representation got right a grudging
invitation to participate this old
newspaper photograph records what was
the star of the show that model in the
center the corbusier's villa savoir what
right desperately needed was a client
and he got the client of his life in
1934 in ej Kaufmann the two certaintly
made a strange pair the merchant Prince
of Pittsburgh and the agrarian populist
who was paranoid about Jews but they
also resembled each other two king-sized
talents with king-sized egos working
together to overcome king-sized
humiliations what made Fallingwater so
radical I believe was the urgent need of
its designer and of its patron to
redress the wrongs the world had done
them for right this meant the mockery of
the German modernists who had outflanked
him for Kaufmann it meant the
anti-jewish snobbery of Pittsburgh some
buildings are born in triumph falling
water was born in crisis Wright was
desperate for work and professional
respect both of which had passed him by
Kaufman was in crisis as his store began
to hemorrhage money in the Depression
Fallingwater
would go up on borrowed money then
Lillian threatened
vorse in 1933 when AJ engaged in a court
fight involving one of his mistresses
the same year EJ and Lillian had to
spring their uncles and cousins trapped
in Nazi Germany and the nation was in
crisis by the summer of 1934 when
Kaufmann summoned right to Pittsburgh
the United States was entering the fifth
year of the depression in few places was
that national crisis worse than in
Pittsburgh where it was not just
economic and social but ecological it
was Pittsburgh that brought right and
Kaufmann together Kaufman sought out
right not to design a house but to
direct twenty four million dollars he
hoped to get in public works as a way of
combating Pittsburgh's chronic
unemployment pollution and flooding the
right Kauffman vision of a revived
Pittsburgh was predictably killed by the
city's politicians and it's jealous
local architects right and Kaufmann
would try again those same civic
improvements in 1948 with this
futuristic structure for downtown
Pittsburgh and again both men would fall
to defeat the core of the right Kauffman
vision would however ultimately went out
and in two places one was Pittsburgh
which finally cleaned itself itself up
in the 1950s but the other I believe was
falling water where it seems to me that
right transferred his aspirations for
Pittsburgh listen to what Wright told
Kaufmann after he first saw Bear Run in
December 1934 visit to the waterfall in
the woods stays with me and the domicile
has taken vague shape and my mind to the
music of the stream compare that to
Reitz lament on the death of his plans
for a revived Pittsburgh how the river
might have been made into a beautiful
feature by damming and pulling it into
blasted water and
driving across the broad dams to the
tune of waterfalls into an up to broad
terraced levels
picturesquely related to the water the
river the dams the pool the sight and
sound of the waterfalls even the broad
terraced levels that Wright had planned
for Pittsburg were all features that
emerge emerged just a few months later
in falling water this assessment of
falling water as Pittsburgh on bear run
makes it into a kind of industrial
trophy set in the bosom of nature and
enhancing nature not by copying it but
by superimposing itself as a literal
second nature
over the real thing this is just how
19th century visitors like Charles
Dickens saw Pittsburgh a second nature
of industry that was as sublime in its
terrifying way as nature itself European
visitors recommended Niagara Falls and
Pittsburgh as the two sites that best
explained America to foreigners the
first conveyed the power of nature in
the New World
the second the power of American
industry falling water gives us both
here then I believe we have the first
two steps in the making of an American
icon the first step was to give EJ
Kaufmann not merely a house but a
National Monument
which is exactly what Fallingwater has
become the second step was to instill in
it a gayness loci as the Romans called
the spirit of a place in its stonework
and it's siting Fallingwater would
celebrate the natural glories of rural
America but in its concrete steel and
glass it would celebrate the no less
magnificent strength of industrial
America an America that was only
temporarily dormant in the 1930s now for
the third step in making the icon
psychologists and counselors advise
clients who are in crisis to go back to
their roots for Frank Lloyd Wright this
meant a return to his early houses the
Gail house in which he had first
explored architectural cubism the
accurse said European modernists had
taken over this house metaphorically now
he would reclaim it for himself right
also reclaimed the Robie house whose
magnificently outstretched roofs he had
first strengthened with hidden steel in
the application of cantilever technology
and his own beloved home Taliesin in
Wisconsin there are dozens of
similarities between this house and
falling water far too many to catalogue
tonight but the most important one I
think is this around 1925 Wright had
dammed up a stream to give Taliesin an
artificial lake and an artificial
waterfall
he then cantilevered the tiny electrical
generator building that you see to the
right of the dam I regard these elements
as previews of falling water but also
there was something else right stacked
rocks against the outer shell of the dam
in order to transform a silent spillway
into a noisy cascade the falling water
and the thundering noise had to be
contrived to tell the Essen but nine
years later right found the same things
ready-made for him at Bear Run it's not
merely the Taliesin and falling water
look-alike they sound alike too
now for the icons fourth step empowered
by his mystic encounter with nature at
Bear Run Wright could at last take
revenge on his modernist rivals in
Europe already in 1931 he had
anathematized them when he wrote I
believe the Corbusier and the group
around him
extremely useful extremely valuable
especially as an enemy right told his
apprentices that he would crush these
enemies by casting falling water in a
specifically European mode it would be
flat-roofed most rare for Wright's works
and industrial strength with none of the
sculpture the art glass or the
marvelously rich decoration he had
provided in all his earlier houses right
turned his battle with the Europeans
into a specifically political crusade
first he mocked the European modernists
as internationalists to make them sound
communist but in 1934 he equated them
outright with Hitler's stormtroopers to
make them into Nazis the European threat
to American architecture in fact loomed
highest in 1935 in the middle of
Wright's design process at falling water
with liqueur BGA's triumphant visit to
the United States and the Museum of
Modern Art's highly publicized
negotiations with Mies van der Rohe ax
who was still living in Germany to
design their new headquarters in New
York Mies and Gropius would arrive in
the US as permanent residence before
falling waters paint was dry but the
great danger to write in 1935 came from
two Europeans who are already here
Rudolph Schindler and Richard Nitra had
not only spurned right after working for
him some years they now exceeded him in
reputation in prosperity and maybe in
creativity right exacted revenge on
these renegades by appropriating
elements of their house designs three
California houses are involved but I
have time tonight to deal only with the
most significant one the Los Angeles
home Nitra created in 1929 for Philip
and Lea Louisville Eric Lloyd Wright
would get livid I observed this once
myself at any suggestion
a link between falling water and the
Louisville house but this strikes me as
a perverse misunderstanding of his
grandfather's genius in my book I argue
that both Wright and Kauffman knew this
house well almost surely inside as well
as out right could no more have
abstained from tinkering with nitrus
design than Bach
could have resisted toying with
Vivaldi's concertos does that make write
derivative know when the furnace of
artistic energy burns as fiercely as it
did for an artificer like right the
original contribution burns off and only
the new work is left
it was the Louisville house not falling
water that made the most astonishing
leap forward of any American home of the
20th century but this pioneering came at
a high price right would have critiqued
the structure of the house as both cheap
and drip and deceptive the concrete was
merely sprayed on not integral to the
house the diagonal bolsters surely the
model for the diagonal bolsters at
falling water but rest'
only a swimming pool not the house
itself and the cantilevers were fakes
since the projections that looked
cantilevered were actually suspended by
steel cables hidden in the framework
above now we start to see why falling
water so captivated Americans in the
1930s EJ Kaufmann knew that the fastest
way for a retailer to lose his shirt was
to get too far ahead of popular taste
the master merchandise er surely saw
that the Louisville house was too
stridently modern too futuristic too far
out for popular tastes falling water
became vastly more popular than the Los
Angeles house not by being more modern
but by being less so the high tech
futurism
of its glass steel and concrete was
tempered by its rough hewn stone walls
and it's comforting links to nature and
by something else remember it wasn't
just the patron and the architect who
are in crisis in the 1930s so was the
whole country like a patient in crisis
the United States also re-examined its
roots in the Great Depression a
horrendous period economically was a
prodigiously rich time for the
exploration of early American folklore
folk art and architecture the architects
and scholars of the 1930s delved into
the roots of American architecture as
they did in no decade before or since we
think immediately of Colonial
Williamsburg dedicated in 1934 but
Williamsburg was largely invented right
must have seen the be wigged Negro
travesty of Williamsburg as a simplistic
way of getting back to American roots
but he was passionately engaged in the
search for architectural roots himself
Fallingwater it seems to me subsumes the
architectural history of the united
states in one building because the most
overlooked of Frank Lloyd Wright's gifts
as a designer was his capacity to mimic
anything in the history of architecture
the man was a sponge I regard him as the
most facile assimilationist in the
history of art and architecture Wright
never tried to hide this true modern
architecture he wrote like classical
architecture has no age it is a
continuation of all the architecture
that has gone before
not a break with it Wright took
inspiration from buildings that were
Mesopotamian medieval Roman renaissance
italian baroque classical french and
japanese if you never saw this before
it's because he hid his track
so well some of those foreign sources
are in falling water - but what
predominates are at subliminal links to
the colonial and prehistoric past of
America the dining area at falling water
for example is entirely but subliminally
colonial the flagstone floor the beamed
ceiling exaggeratedly low the massive
hearth with its swiveled kettle the
simple table and the credenza with the
best family china these are all features
of the timber framed houses of 17th
century New England right remembered
those houses because he lived five or
six years in the Boston suburb of
Weymouth Abigail Adams old hometown
turning around in the living room our
our attention Falls partly on the
expanse of Pittsburgh plate glass but
equally on the rough stone walls and the
massive stone piers here
I think Wright has captured the
simplicity and solemnity of a Kiva the
sacred underground chambers that the
Native Americans of the Southwest built
by the thousands you may object did
right know those prehistoric monuments
absolutely he spent months in the
southwest precisely when he was
designing fallingwater
in his mind moreover he told Coughlin he
was driving 300 miles one way just to
see some of the Anasazi cliff dwellings
probably at Mesa Verde still you might
object would right have had any reason
to design a building based on the Kiva
prototype and I'll answer again
absolutely he not only would have he did
the darkened semi underground chamber
that Wright designed for himself at
Taliesin West in Arizona still bears not
only the form but the name of a Kiva no
word is used more
to describe falling water than timeless
every architect would like to make her
building timeless but how does she do
that for write the solution lay in
integrating his buildings with nature
which is the most timeless thing we
humans deal with and with history the
steps leading from falling waters West
Terrace to its penthouse maybe the most
lyrical in the United States they are
modern in their reinforced concrete
technology and indeed cantilever it out
like the house itself but in form they
allude to Adobe which in 1935 was still
the common building material of the
Native Americans when Wright sojourned
among them that year these adobe steps
lead to the Kiva at Pueblo San Ildefonso
in New Mexico cave-like and dark inside
falling water is itself a kind of Kiva a
sacred refuge for the Kaufman's
right grounded and enriched falling
water made it timeless really through
the layer upon layer of humanistic
meanings he bestowed on it now the last
step in the creation of any American
icon making falling water famous this
was not easy even for merchandising
genius like EJ Kaufmann the place was
brand new not hallowed by history no
celebrity had slept there nor ever would
this was no Graceland it wasn't even
Neverland
and you couldn't find it deep in the
woods by the mason-dixon line it was and
remains the hardest Frank Lloyd Wright
house to visit more people glimpse the
Guggenheim Museum in a day if only from
a Fifth Avenue bus then see falling
water in an entire year
so Kaufman termed to the mass media he
pressured his business associate Henry R
loose to put right and falling water on
the cover of Time in January 1938 the
first architect and the first building
to get such exposure for good measure
Kaufmann got another of his business
associates William Randolph Hearst to
drop the barricades that had kept
modernism out of Hurst's conservative
magazines like Town and Country and led
falling water in its pages as the very
first example of modern architecture in
the Hearst publications Kaufmann
publicized his house so well that the
communist inspired new masses praised
falling water - surely the only point on
which the Communists and William
Randolph Hearst ever agreed also in
January 1938 the Museum of Modern Art
made Fallingwater the subject of a
special exhibit what a switch the pariah
of 1932 returning in triumph as the king
of modern architecture may as well have
expected the FBI to mount a special show
in honor of babyface Nelson
unlike the architectural icons of
America buildings like Mount Vernon that
are known but not venerated overseas
Fallingwater
achieved instant icon status around the
globe
it was splashed in architectural in
general magazines in England France
Holland Finland Argentina Japan as I
illustrate here Italy
everywhere but in Stalin Estrella and
Nazi Germany how long did it take to
make falling water into the most famous
house of the 20th century
I'd say eight weeks no visitors studied
the falling water show at MoMA more
attentively than the novelist and
political thinker Ian Rand Rand had been
struggling for almost half a decade
trying to write a book that would speak
of the triumphs of modern architecture
its original title was second-hand lives
but how could she write such a book when
there had not occurred a triumph of
modern architecture as soon as she
visited the falling water show at MoMA
she renamed her novel The Fountainhead
an explicit echo of falling water and
she put both the Kaufman's and their
magical house in the text in encode five
million readers have bought The
Fountainhead since 1943 and probably
several hundred million more possibly
only in their sleep have watched the
1949 movie in theatres or on television
with Gary Cooper as the character based
on right in the end none of its
promoters not right or Kaufman not loose
or Hurst not an R and sold falling water
to the American people as cunningly as
the house sold itself here it is on the
pages of The New Yorker which wittily
imagines a whole suburb full of falling
waters each with an identical waterfall
but it's still not obvious why America
took falling water to heart so fast the
country had welcomed the antediluvian
Supreme Court building just three years
before why now the somewhat irrational
enthusiasm for a building exactly its
opposite that's one of the paradoxes of
falling water
the house that is the embodiment of
timelessness went up with perfect timing
fallingwater enjoyed enormous buzz
because the public saw it as
specifically American architecture the
inside cover of life for January 10 1938
ran bill hedrick's newly famous
photograph with the caption that called
fallingwater quote architecture as
thoroughly indigenous to America as the
earth and rocks from which it Springs
the next year life wrapped itself even
more patriotically in the Stars and
Stripes when it sure did sri ders that
writes Johnson wax headquarters was
quote genuine American architecture
owing nothing to foreign inspiration
different from anything ever built in
the world before such a jingoistic claim
made sense only in naked ly political
terms formerly speaking it was baloney
and why the Stars and Stripes I believe
what heightened America's love for
Fallingwater were the two defining
events of the 1930s the depression and
the drift into global warfare the house
appeared before the public at the exact
bottom of the depression which was as
you know not the stock market crash of
1929 nor the fall in employment and
industrial production of 1932 the true
depths of the depression came in
December of 1937 when production and
employment disastrously slipped even
lower and any tentative optimism
vanished word of a luxury house called
falling water reached the world
one month later here are some of the
ways in which I feel falling water was
bound up with the Great Depression like
Jesse Owens at the Berlin Olympics of
1932 sorry 36 the racehorse Seabiscuit
of nine
18:37 and The Wizard of Oz movie of 1939
fallingwater fed Americans need for
escapism in one of the country's most
terrible moments like Frank Capra's
contemporary movies mr. deeds goes to
town and mr. Smith goes to Washington
fallingwater gave Americans reassurance
on the core values of their beleaguered
society like the movies again
Fallingwater allowed the poor a
vicarious association with the rich it
needed only Fred Astaire and Ginger
Rogers dancing up on those balconies
fallingwater correspondent with
america's growing appreciation of nature
and its disenchantment with the cities
and technology Charlie Chaplin was in
mesh in the gears of an infernal
contraption in modern times in 1936 the
Hindenburg blew itself up in 1937 the
history of the radio broadcast of War of
the Worlds came in 1938 the same year as
falling water falling water nicely
balanced America's fascination with
modernism and its fears of it it offered
an uplifting modernism the way a few
years later Aaron Copland would weave
the shaker melody tis the gift to be
simple into his hauntingly beautiful
Appalachian Spring the slick modernism
of the 1930s such as one saw the Chicago
and the New York World's Fairs presented
America with a future but not it passed
the conservative architecture of the
1930s gave Americans a past but no
future Fallingwater gave the country
both past and future the other factor
that made Fallingwater
stand out in such sharp relief in 1938
was surely the shadow of Hitler the year
that began with Frank Lloyd Wright on
the cover
time ended with Hitler as times man of
the year Hitler picked January 10 1938
for the speech in which he swore to
avenge the ten million Germans living
outside the fatherland Henry Luce picked
the very same day to use three of his
four magazines to tell the world about
falling water neither right nor Kaufmann
I believe gave Fallingwater
an overt political reading and if they
had those readings were sure to be
contradictory Wright was a prominent
isolationist and America firster who
Wormley supported Charles Lindbergh when
he came home with the ayran cross from
Hitler with as many links to Germany
Kaufmann was a strong interventionist in
1939 he can vote a high-level conference
at Fallingwater
with Albert Einstein presiding to
strategize how to free the Jews trapped
in Nazi Germany nonetheless for both
Wright and Coughlin fallingwater
represented a triumph of America over
Germany for right it was his sweet
triumph over the Bauhaus for Kaufmann
and for most Americans who thought about
it
Fallingwater was an affirmation of
America as a refuge for modernism itself
again the timing was perfect the same
architectural forum issue that launched
fallingwater
in January 1938 carried this item
mocking Nazi architecture just months
before it had reported the Nazi shut
down of the Bauhaus born just when
modern architecture was dying in Germany
fallingwater had to be seen as a
standard-bearer both for Americanism and
modernism it helped change Americans
view of modern architecture from
something foreign and suspect to
something that was homegrown even
patriotic what had seemed eccentric
foreign and stuck up at MoMA's
architecture show in 1932 had by 1938
turned into an occasionally funny but
likeable thing like Kaufman's funny but
likable friend professor Einstein in
another couple of years most Americans
probably thought the United States had
invented modernism all by itself like
nylons it goes against my background as
a scholar but at times I wonder whether
Fallingwater was not conceived by some
law of unintended consequences if EJ
Kaufman had not been ostracized by
Pittsburgh society he would not have
needed to build himself an architectural
marvel and if Hitler had not taken over
Germany in 1933 Kaufman might well have
hired his architect there in 1934 and
not in Wisconsin if Frank Lloyd Wright
had not been humiliated at MoMA
he might have lacked the fire to design
a building so radical that it would
regain for him his old standing in
modern architecture falling waters
makeup also demanded a bucolic natural
setting near a city of great industrial
strength and for its launch into world
fame it needed a circulation gimmick by
Henry Luce a brilliant image by a rookie
photographer and Ayn Rand working her
way out of writer's block falling waters
popularity depended as well on the new
cultural values spawned by the
depression and on a heightened American
nationalism as the country moved to war
in the end though and despite all these
coincidences the building owes its fame
to nothing but itself there was never a
house like falling water before and
there will never be a house like falling
water again
thank you so much now as part of your
admission ticket you get to quiz the
author and of course I'm delighted to
have questions I'm asked to ask you to
array ourselves at one of those two
microphones and shoot away hi I just
wanted to know how long the Kaufman's
lived there and whether it was actually
a practical house to live in some of the
right stuff wasn't so practical yes
there were those buckets as an honorable
sign of modernism the Kaufman's
basically week ended there only it's not
even a summer house they went up to
Ontario for the summers and effectively
they were there from 38 till the
beginning of the war the house is
basically closed during the war and at
the end the dynamics and that amazingly
dysfunctional family had changed again
and it was used very very little very
sparingly actually the house was a kind
of billboard you can live in it like I
suppose you can live behind a billboard
but it had achieved its great purpose
just by appearing around the world in
photographs hi have two questions one is
the the great myth about the design you
know when supposedly there was the story
of you know Kaufman's coming ejs coming
to get his you know see the design and
coffee you know
rights they're trying to you know you
know yes oh yeah yeah I've been working
on this for months and you know
allegedly just for you know like an hour
or something and then also some based on
the the fact that the house had to be
recently reinforced any comments on
rights engineering skills thanks a lot
the to the first question I had hoped to
provoke some controversy by my book on
the
American icon instead I was unprepared
for the rapturous reception everybody
seems to like it and the new masses has
ceased publication only about 70 years
ago but that a tiny spark of controversy
is alive some of the old guard of the
Taliesin apprentices not however any who
were there especially Edgar Tafel who is
alive he's 92 or 93 he was absolutely
there while falling water does not was
designed and he supports me entirely in
my interpretation but others don't
what's the fight about I do not believe
the usual presentation of the myth is
that Frank Lloyd Wright couldn't be
bothered to design the house so he
waited nine months in fact he waited
nine months and four days that's pretty
darn good for biological or organic
allegories about creation the
apprentices were paying Frank Lloyd
Wright more than students at Yale or
Harvard for the privilege of living
there cooking his meals planting his
fields chopping down the wood for the
fireplaces and doing not only their
laundry but also his and Olga vanna's so
they were part of the picture but I
think they were not extremely well
informed so let's start with one aspect
of the myth Frank Lloyd Wright gave at
least half a dozen very specific hints
about what Fallingwater would look like
during those nine months for example the
idea that EJ Kaufmann was so clueless
that he didn't even know on which bank
of bear run the house was to rise that's
completely unacceptable he knew
perfectly well so right secondly knew
six weeks in advance
when Kauffman would appear that day he
just didn't tell the apprentices and he
did in fact appear at breakfast that day
September 22nd 1935 with blank sheets of
paper on which the house began to gather
in its details with astonishing rapidity
I don't believe that this was Frank
Lloyd Wright's first engagement with
paper in the Fallingwater design I am
certain he had been thinking about it
and had been sketching it out and what
really offended some of the old
apprentices I say it was drawn up in his
bedroom well if you go to Taliesin in
Wisconsin you'll see that the master
bedroom was occupied by olga vana down
the hall just as Lilian occupied the
master bedroom at Fallingwater
and Frank Lloyd Wright had a tiny
bedroom it it had a little daybed in it
and he would work through the night he
says so repeatedly he's quoted he gets
up at 3 or 4 in the morning
works on the designs goes to sleep and
then starts anew in the morning so I
compare this to Winston Churchill or a
very experienced orator who writes the
entire speech out over night and then in
the morning looks like a genius doesn't
even glance at his or her notes right
that's what I think occurred there about
the engineering we're even less well
informed but we know that right twice
and lore well he once enlarged the
diameter of the rebar the steel rods in
the reinforced concrete he agreed to
that a first time the second time they
were enlarged probably he knew nothing
about it he had been deceived by EJ
Kaufman and Kaufman's team of engineers
in Pittsburgh now what does a merchant
know about engineering well the old
Vegh reputation was that Kaufman had
spent a year at Yale so I found out from
the Yale archives he was in the
engineering school he actually knew
something about it but take heed because
I warn you in the book that Wright was a
great merchant he sold something like
4,000 Japanese prints over the years to
the Metropolitan Museum he made more
money trafficking in Japanese prints
than he did from architecture so here's
a highly inflammable combination the
merchant who has a smattering of
engineering meet the architect who sees
himself as a merchant it was a terrible
crossover in their rules so as far as we
can a judge there was not enough steel
and perhaps not placed at the most
opportune levels in the cantilevers and
indeed they were coming very close to
collapse in 1997 when the house had to
be cradled the house is entirely
restored today through post-tensioning
and it was a wonderful privilege for me
to be able to see the house with its
guts ripped out in order to actually see
the case of 1936 for Maya with my own
eyes